the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thurs and a
song of ice and fire video
all right my friends i am finally ready
to dive back into my chapter breakdowns
in this video as you all know i was
making a video on every chapter
and every book this is a good way for
the non-book readers to find out what
happens in the original version
of this amazing story in this video i
will be discussing what happens in lady
catelyn stark's second chapter
so let's see what she thinks about as we
see the story
unfold through her eyes this chapter
begins shortly after they held the feast
at winterfell to celebrate robert
baratheon's arrival
ned stark and his wife lady catelyn are
now in their bedroom
and we soon find out that they actually
just got done having sex
lady catelyn thinks about how of all the
rooms inside winterfell
their bed chambers were the hottest in
fact
they were so hot they seldom ever had to
light a fire
the winterfell castle had been built
over natural hot springs
and the scalding waters that rushed
through its walls and chambers were like
blood running through a man's body
this must be really nice when you
consider they do live in the north where
the winters can be very harsh
i bet you their bedroom is nice and hot
from all that steamy sex they just had
as well
but i will leave those scenes up to your
own imagination
luckily for lady catelyn winterfell did
have these natural hot springs in the
area
it was the difference between life and
death in the winter
it never really made a difference for
the starks though they were men of the
north
who were made for this cold weather but
this wasn't something that catelyn
ever really enjoyed since she grew up in
the south
now i find this to be interesting
because the crypts beneath winterfell
are always cold although the rest of the
stark's castle is very warm
this along with many other things has
always made me believe there might be
something made of ice
locked in the crypts of winterfell i
made a whole theory video about this
before
i will have that link down below if you
would like to watch that video
so after ned and catelyn finished their
nighttime activities
ned rolled off her as he had done a
thousand times before
the first thing he did was walk across
the room so he could throw open the
windows to allow some fresh air inside
then he stood at the window naked as he
looked outside at the sky
lady catelyn wrapped herself up in the
blankets to stay warm
she watched her husband standing there
and thought that ned somehow was looking
smaller
and more vulnerable sort of like the man
she had wed at riverrun
nearly 15 years ago she also thought
about how her loins were still
aching from the urgency of his
lovemaking she thought
it was one of those good kind of aches
and she thinks about how it has been
over three years since they had baby
rickon
she was hoping she could still give ned
another son before they got any older
then the conversation changes when they
start discussing what robert and ned
were talking about
earlier that day once again this is
where the books are different from the
show
in the game of thrones television show
lady catlin does not want ned to go to
king's landing with robert
in the show she says everything she can
to keep ned from writing south
now this is the exact opposite of what
happens in the book
immediately after ned says i will refuse
him
catelyn sits up in bed and says you
cannot you must not
he will not understand that he is a king
now
and kings are not like other men if you
refuse to serve him
he will wonder why and sooner or later
he will begin to suspect that you oppose
him
but ned shakes his head refusing to
believe it
he knows robert he knows that robert
would never harm him or his family
after all they grew up together closer
than brothers
i mean sure robert might get angry and
he might even yell at ned
but they love each other and within a
week they would laugh about it
ned reminds his wife i know this man
lady catelyn doesn't agree though
she says you knew this man this new king
is a stranger to you now then she thinks
about what her husband had found in the
woods earlier that day
she remembers the dead dire wolf in the
snow and the broken antler that was
found in her throat
in lady catelyn's mind she had to make
ned understand
this is a bad omen robert wrote all this
way to see ned
he wrote all this way to give ned these
honors he cannot throw them back in his
face
by refusing to go now you know this
can't be an easy choice for ned
he most likely does want to help his
lifelong friend but on the other hand
he doesn't want to have to leave his
family or his home either
he knows he belongs in the north but he
is later given enough of a good reason
to go
now we begin to find out some more
information about these characters when
ned and catelyn are discussing robert's
offer to marry joffrey and sansa
as of right now ned doesn't think sons
is old enough for marriage
but lady catelyn reminds him she was
that same age when her father promised
her to ned's brother brandon
this only reminds ned that none of this
was meant for him
it was all meant for brandon he should
have married catelyn
he should have taken over winterfell he
should have had everything
and he would have had he only lived
after brandon stark's death
ned had married lady catelyn instead in
the shadow of his dead brother still
laid between them
as did the other the shadow of the woman
he would not name
the woman who had borne him is bastard's
son or so catelyn thought
there will be a lot more on this later
this is when they're interrupted by a
knock on the door maester lewin informs
them someone left a small box on his
desk
and his observatory inside that box was
a fine new lens
well maester lewin knowing that a lens
helps one see better
realizes there's more to this box than
meets the eye
he discovers there is a letter hiding
inside of the false bottom of the box
someone obviously did not want this
letter to fall into the wrong hands
now this scene alone is basically
foreshadowing the entire story
everything is not what it seems there is
a bit of mystery to basically every
chapter and every book
it's only after reading each book
several times that you start to discover
or uncover new things like the box mace
draymond received
he reveals the letter was meant for lady
catlin's eyes only
the letter was sealed with a blob of
blue wax the wax had the moon and falcon
seal of house aaron
this is a message from caitlyn's sister
liza
everyone in the room gets a bit nervous
and catelyn even admits that she's
afraid
she says she can feel the grief and the
message only later will we find out
littlefinger is behind all of this
not only the letter but john aaron's
death as well
littlefinger wanted the starks and the
lannisters to fight each other
because this will open up so many
opportunities for him to climb that
ladder
in the letter liza says john aaron was
murdered by the lannisters
at first ned does not want to believe
this he thinks liza has lost her damn
mind
and maybe ned knows liza better than
catelyn does because he's not that far
off
however catelyn believes her sister she
doesn't think liza would go through all
this trouble to get her
message unless it was legitimate now
this gives ned
even more reasons to want to stay home
ned wants to avoid king's landing
and all of its backstabbing maester
lewin and lady catelyn do not agree with
them
if ned does love robert like a brother
then he cannot leave him alone
surrounded by lannisters and the capital
this makes ned look out the window again
and think about what he must do
he knows he's about to have to say
goodbye to his home and some of his
family
ned says my father rode south once but
he never came home again
and this is some foreshadowing for what
will ultimately happen to ned
this will be the last time he is ever in
winterfell with all of his family
he essentially accepts his own fate with
him gone
rob will need to learn how to take over
things in the north a stark
must always remain in winterfell this is
when they decide
what children will stay and what
children will go with ned
now what's interesting is bran was meant
to go to king's landing with ned
obviously that never happens because
bran is eventually thrown out of the
window by jaime
but i can't help but wonder how
different things would have been if bran
left with ned
when catelyn thinks about bran leaving
her she says make sure he stays off the
walls
you know how brain loves to climb
everything this may also be some of the
foreshadowing for what will happen
in one of bran's upcoming chapters now
they have to decide what to do with jon
snow
as soon as jon's name is mentioned ned
can feel his wife's anger rise inside of
her
it's no secret she hates jon snow
now lady catelyn knows many men father
bastards
in fact she was not surprised at all
when she found out ned fathered a
bastard during their first year of
marriage
she thinks he had a man's needs after
all and they had spent the entire year
apart
while ned was fighting in robert's
rebellion in her mind
ned was welcomed to whatever solace he
may need in between the battles
however the starks were not like other
men
ned brought his bastard home and called
him sun
for all the north to see when the wars
were finally over at last
in catelyn road to winterfell jon and
his wet nurse had already taken up
residence in the castle
and this is what hurt her the most ned
would not even speak of the mother
not so much as a word but a castle has
secrets
and catelyn did hear maids repeating
stories they heard from the lips of
ned's soldiers
oh yes the hallways of winterfell were
not that much different than the
hallways of a high school
there were whisperings of sir arthur
dane the sword of the morning
deadliest of the knights of ares
kingsguard and how their young lord had
slain him in single combat
they also talked about how afterward ned
carried sir arthur dane's sword back to
his beautiful young sister who awaited
him in a castle
named starfall on the shores of the
summer sea
and this right here is one of the many
reasons why some fans believe
jon's mother is actually ashara dane now
i don't think i need to get into this
we all know what the real answer is by
now but lady catelyn doesn't know what
really happened
therefore she has all the same questions
we once had before we knew
so one night she had asked ned about
this ashara dane
this was a big mistake that was the only
time in all their years that ned had
ever frightened her
never ask me about johnny said cold is
ice
he is my blood and that is all you need
to know
and now i will learn why you heard that
name my lady
from this day on ashara dane's name was
never whispered and winterfell again
whoever jon snow's mother had been ned
must have loved her fiercely
because there was nothing lady catelyn
could do to get ned to send the boy away
this was the one and only thing she
could never forgive him for
she had loved her husband with all of
her heart but she could never love jon
lady catelyn even thinks she would have
forgiven ned
if he had a dozen different bastards so
long as they were out of her sight
jon was never out of her sight though
and the older he got
the more he looked just like ned what
made this even worse was the fact that
jon looked more like ned
than any of their sons that made catelyn
furious
i mean she really hated this boy
now i can forgive catelyn for a lot of
her mistakes but i can never forgive her
for the way she looked at jon
now i will say on the one hand i
understand why this would bother her
i would be very angry if my wife showed
up with another child that wasn't mine
but if anything those feelings should
fall on ned
not the innocent child who did not ask
for this
the fact that catelyn even wishes jon
would have suffered severe injuries
or even death makes me very upset with
her
later on after bran is thrown from the
window
jon visits him before he leaves for the
night's watch i know all of you remember
that scene very well from the show
but what happens in the books is so much
darker
right as john is leaving the room lady
catlin says his name
something she had never done before now
actually just think about that for a
second
john has been living under the same roof
as catelyn
well over a decade yet she has never
even said his name
until now when jean looks back to see
what she wants catelyn says
it should have been you john should have
been the one who fell from the window
jon should be the one who was laying on
his death bed
now let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen i was
absolutely disgusted when i first read
that
i could not believe she would say
something like that to john
this sounds like something cersei would
say i was shocked to say the least
anyways as they're deciding what to do
with jon
catelyn says he cannot stay here he is
your son ned
not mine i will not have him here ned
says he can't take john south with him
either
a boy with a bastard's name in king's
landing you know what they will say
about him
he will be shunned this means nothing to
lady catelyn
she doesn't even flinch she fires back
with
well they say your friend robert has
fathered a dozen bastards himself
ned fires right back and none of them
have ever been seen with him in king's
landing
the lannister woman has seen to that how
can you be so damnably cruel catelyn
he is only a boy catelyn saw that ned
was furious now
he would have said more and maybe even
worse but maester lewin interrupted them
when he says there may be another
solution your brother benjen
came to me very recently letting me know
that jon wants to join the night's watch
ned looked absolutely shocked he wants
to join the night's watch
lady catlin doesn't say a word she wants
ned to work this
out on his own but deep down we all know
what she wants to happen
she would have gladly gave the maester a
kiss when he mentioned the night's watch
this was like music to her ears she
thought this was a great solution
jon could be like the sun benjen would
never have but this isn't the only
reason she favored that idea
this would also mean that jon would
father no sons
therefore catelyn would not have to
worry about anyone getting in the way of
her grandchildren taking winterfell away
from them
she doesn't want the stark home ending
up in the hands of a bastard
or his children now ned thinks about
what the maester said
john is so young if he had asked this
when he was a man grown
that would be one thing but a boy of 14
years old
a very hard sacrifice maester lewin
agreed
yet these are hard times my lord his
road will be no harder than yours or
your ladies
that made catelyn think about the three
children she would lose when ned takes
them south the king's landing
it was not easy for her to stay silent
then ned stood there gazing out the
window
his long face silent and thoughtful
finally
he sighed and said very well
i guess it's for the best i will speak
to benjen about it later
it will be a fortnight before we're all
ready to leave
i want jon to enjoy these last few days
of summer before he finds out
where he will most likely spend the rest
of his life the summer will end soon
enough
in their childhood as well when the time
comes
i will tell jon myself
well there you have it folks this is how
the chapter ends
as you can see things are not getting
any easier for hal
stark ned reluctantly decides to go to
king's landing to be
robert's hand this decision will
ultimately
fracture their entire family some of
them go to king's landing
some of them stay in winterfell and jon
snow leaves for the wall
this will be the last time we see this
family all together
in winterfell everything will only get
more interesting
and complex from here on out now as of
right now
these chapters are still very similar to
how things were done in the show
but it won't be long before some of
these characters go in entirely
different directions
i hope you all will come back for those
videos as well i look forward to
discussing those chapters with you
for now i want to thank everyone for
watching the video i really appreciate
that as always
and i also want to thank those of you
who support the channel
i cannot thank you enough for that have
a great day everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you